One of the most calming things that societies
have ever devised is the lullaby. In almost
every culture there has ever been, mothers
have rocked and sung their babies to sleep.
A humbling point that a lullaby reveals is
that it’s not necessarily the words of a
song that make us feel more tranquil. The
baby doesn’t understand what’s being said
but the sound has its effect all the same.
The baby is showing us that we are all tonal
creatures long before we are creatures of
understanding.
As adults, we grasp the significance of words of course, but there remains a sensory
level which cuts through and affects us far more
than an argument or idea ever could. The
musician can, at points, trump anything the
philosopher might tell us.
Ancient Greek mythology
was fascinated by the story of the famous
musician Orpheus. At one point he had to rescue
his wife from the underworld. To get there
he needed to make his way past Cerberus the
ferocious three-headed dog who guarded the
entrance to the land of the dead. Orpheus
was said to have played such sweet, enchanting
music that the wild beast calmed down and
became – for a while – mild and docile.
The Greeks were giving themselves a reminder
of the psychological power of music. Orpheus
didn’t reason with Cerberus, he didn’t
try to explain how important it was that he
should be allowed to pass, he didn’t speak
about how much he loved his wife and how much
he wanted her back. Cerberus was – as we
ourselves are at times of distress – pretty
much immune to reason. But he was still open
to influence. It was just a matter of finding the
right channel to reach him. When we feel anxious
or upset, kindly people sometimes try to comfort
us by pointing to facts and ideas: they try
to influence our thinking and – via careful
arguments – to quieten our distress. But,
as with Cerberus, the most effective way to
deal with the problem may simply be to play
us some music.
We might need to be quietened and made mild (by a lullaby, a Chopin prelude
or something by Natalie Merchant), before
we are in any position to listen to reason.
Music is the greatest mood adjustor we have ever invented. Its benefits can be broken
down as follows:
Music can reunite us with feelings we need but have lost touch with. It reconciles
us to a sadness within, which we have had to be too
be brave and stoic not to feel.
It is the axe that
breaks the frozen sea within us.
Music can lend dignity to our sorrows, framing and containing
what might otherwise be unmanageable grief.
Music is there for us like a comforting parent
in moments of despair. Music returns us to
life, gently nudging us to return to the side
of generosity and hope. We can follow in music's
grooves of confidence, when our own will is
sagging.
Music is there to take us beyond the everyday, to transcend the ordinary and survey
ourselves from a lofty height.
Music reconnects us with our instinctual, bodily selves when
reason, logic and discipline are in danger
of crushing us. Music breaks down the barriers
between strangers – urging us to see what
we have in common, rather than what divides
us. We fully discover our debt to music when
we can acknowledge just how powerless we sometimes
are to change our moods through reason alone.
A good life doesn't only need a library of
ideas: it requires a vast and ever-changing
playlist that can systematically tug us back
to our more hopeful, sensitive and resilient selves.